[Music]
whoa where to begin this week well in
case you missed it I was off the grid
for an entire month from August 4th to
September 5th and I have the facial hair
to prove it as you can see my beard
actually even has a twitter account
already which somehow is a real thing on
the internet over the past 30 days I've
had no phone no email no Twitter and no
digital noise in my life whatsoever I
also didn't watch any news or have one
single conversation about politics the
entire time I was gone believe it or not
what I did do during this time was a
combination of writing my book relaxing
doing some gardening taking long walks
with my dog and spending time with
friends and family as I said in our live
stream yesterday I am beyond incredibly
grateful and humbled by those of you who
support the Rubin report on patreon and
on PayPal for letting me and my crew
carve out this precious bit of time to
rest rejuvenate and come back more focus
than ever before I also learned a couple
life lessons this past month including
that writing a book is far more intense
and introspective than you can possibly
imagine so just give me a little more
time on that one unsurprisingly the news
cycle kept on spinning without me and
I'm just now catching up on everything
that I missed from the terror attack in
Barcelona to the events in
Charlottesville to the devastation of
Hurricane Harvey and now Trump's
reversal of daca there's no shortage of
news for me to get caught up with for
this direct message though I want to
look forwards and not backwards and
instead share some thoughts on the
future of what we're going to be doing
around here
I consider today to be the first episode
of season 3 of the Rubin report our
first season of the Rubin report as an
interview show began two years ago when
we launched on Ora TV with my interview
with Sam Harris over the next year the
show began to blow up as we focus more
and more on free speech on the battle
for logic and reason to be put back into
public discourse about a year ago we
left Ora and went fully independent so
we could a hundred percent control the
content we were creating as well as the
business behind it I consider this phase
of our show to be season two I don't
know if any show out there has a more
diverse guestlist over the past two
years and
I intend on expanding on that going
deeper on the important issues that
we're talking about and more your
support allows me to do what I think is
right instead of focusing on what
content will make a dime whether
YouTube's deep monetizes us or the
algorithms work against us because of
dangerous or controversial topics that
we cover the Rubin report will continue
to cover the issues that really matter
having the detailed nuanced
conversations you'll never get on
mainstream news with this in mind I'm
thrilled to be launching season three of
the Rubin report with one of the few
people I find that consistently makes
some sense of the endless noise that
were constantly bombarded with Phil
DeFranco host of the aptly titled Phil
DeFranco show is one of the guys I turn
to to get unbiased sourced and credible
analysis of current events as one of the
first big youtubers around he's had an
interesting personal and political
evolution himself something he's done in
front of the camera for years now our
friends at learn Liberty are partnering
with us for this episode and Phil is
requested that his honorarium for this
show be given to the polycystic disease
foundation cause which is very personal
to him after the show learned Liberty
will be writing a check of 1,500 dollars
to the foundation and you can find out
more about this cause at PKB cure org
all right I'm back
I'm bearded and I'm ready to talk about
the important issues of the day if
there's a specific issue you want us to
cover or a special person you want us to
talk to this season let us know in the
comments right down below since I've
been off the internet for a while I
assume that all YouTube comments are
positive and friendly now so I look
forward to seeing what you come up with
[Music]
all right people I am officially back on
the grid this week and joining me to
make some sense of the world that I
missed is host of the aptly titled
philip defranco show right here on the
youtubes bill DeFranco I love that I
love that you've put that on me of
trying to make sense of whatever the
hell it is we're living in right now
well I have to tell you you have a lot
of pressure on you because I could have
selected anybody for the beginning of
season three I'm back on the grid
I lost my razor I'm trying to figure out
what happened and for some reason I
chose you
I'm loving this though I'm just jealous
I know that was saying it before but I
want to go on the record I'm just very
jealous of the facial hair I I feel good
about it maybe maybe you could grow out
a little something oh no I can grow out
a little something a little something
it's not a actual something yeah but
you're a respectable guy and you're
you're doing videos every day
mm-hm - see you change your look I don't
I don't know what I want a pretty
consistent look over the years yes i all
i do is i fluctuate sixty pounds
depending on the stress level of that
time because I will say I'm so glad the
timing worked out but I was still a
little iffy on doing this because I know
that side angle and I don't like from
the side and that was like that was the
50-50 coin flip of if I do this or not
that's hilarious so much I was like yes
well so okay so there's a few things
going on here so one of the reasons I
wanted to have you on was just to catch
me up on some of the stuff and I wanted
it to be from somebody that I think is
consistently trying to be honest and and
do good stuff but you are an insanely
busy person it turned out that we live
literally within walking distance of
each other which is almost impossible in
LA and yet we were trying to connect for
like a year and it couldn't happen when
it finally did you got in your car and
realized that it was a half a second oh
yeah I was cuz I never actually go on
this specific street yeah and so I gone
off the highway and I was like oh oh
what for a second I thought I was
getting like pranked right I was like
okay I'm just driving home yeah but uh
ya know it's crazy but that's also I
think that's very much la but it doesn't
matter where you none of us lay exist in
the real world we just were point a
point B right there's no in-between we
got some people some normies walking
around the neighborhood
being outside living life well I'm God
or you now for the past month but yeah I
mean for the most part I'm in one place
or another yeah you are a busy guy
because all I did for the last month
when I was here beside was doing some
writing and some gardening but I was
walking my dog a lot and I kept thinking
I'm gonna have to see him at some point
cuz I'm walking around for hours
aimlessly never but it proves my point
that you are you're a busy guy
yes well I'm trying to make a lot of cut
yeah well the goal is to make more like
I definitely so right now we put out
across the two channels 8 videos a week
but the next the big next step that
we've been kind of building up to the
launch of is a daily 1 hour live show
just finding the right people to be
involved what I've done in the past has
been more comedy first and then news was
attached to it for me now the next step
is is news first and then make it
relatable make it funny but that's
that's a second thing because I think
people need to be informed or at least
informed of what other people are saying
yeah yeah so as if you're not busy
enough just with the show you also have
a second child do I believe in two days
from two days unless your producer gets
a phone call in which case I will have
to hop out of this for the record I was
willing to let you keep the phone in
front of know it's which we normally
don't do but you said no no no if the
baby's coming the baby can wait wait
what it's very important no but your
phone is in there in case something
happens it could happen yes
why are you ready for a second one yeah
it'll be great and it's also it's an
excuse to take a week off so that I can
be home try and make some normalcy in
the you know the beginning of the chaos
but I'm excited but two and done two and
done no more don't want to be
outnumbered two is great fair enough so
for people who don't know you yes well I
mean I'm on YouTube do right but there
might be somebody here that that doesn't
know you funny people they don't know
you what what possessed you to start
talking to the camera being really being
really bored and in college I've been on
YouTube now for over 10 years anytime I
mention who I used to watch back in the
day 1% of my audience knows who I'm
talking about but it was a lot of
talking heads and I think it's a lot of
what's people still feel today and why
they jump into it they see
people that may be doing a good job but
they think they can do as good or they
want to be that great or they think
they're garbage way better and that's
and that's kind of how I jumped into it
and I wanted to talk about the news
because I just wanted to talk to someone
about everything that was happening
right that's it's I've always been like
a very like a loner kind of loser type
stuck to myself the close I get to
talking to someone I found myself trying
to jump into things like Magic the
Gathering cards so I just had someone to
talk to about something because now
people wanted to talk about news in high
school right
so yeah just really bored really poor in
college started making videos talking
about current events
pretty much anything back in the day to
chase the front page but it was always
it was always news I was always
conversation but that's really it
when did you realize that it was
actually like becoming something more
than just like taking care of a little
lonely I like to think that it's it's
right around the time that I dropped out
of college because I was at this point
where my grades were starting to fail I
was realized I was blaming YouTube for
it but I was my heart really just wasn't
in it anymore I had for like seven years
my dad told me like you're gonna be a
doctor and so I was in the pre-med
program and I hate that I hated it my
brain did not work for that skill set
and and then one day right when I was
about to quit YouTube YouTube gave me a
call and inform me about the partner
program right kind of kind of like this
why were you gonna quit you know because
you thought it was affecting your grades
so yeah you were trying to yeah well at
least yeah that's what I was thinking
and then the moment I realized and they
said I wasn't making a lot more money
than I initially was right and so I was
like oh well screw this like I I'll just
I'll just focus on this I'll drop out
it'll be fine and it was not fine
initially I had to you know just figure
out a way to make it work for for
several years and then I think once I
once I finally found myself in
California with with some of like the
old faces shaycarl kmg Danny diamonds to
start maker that's the moment I think I
realized okay this is this is like a
real thing this could be a real real
thing it's not just
me in a room by myself this is this is
the rise of something new do you look at
that with a certain amount of nostalgia
now like sort of like the good old days
like a little bit one kind of knew what
was happening you didn't realize whether
this was gonna be a money thing or a
career thing or what and just everybody
didn't have a handle on how big this all
could be I think for me it's it's never
really
so obviously the money is fantastic the
money is an enabler and I will I will
not talk [ __ ] on money but for me it is
it is really what we're putting out
there right yes I put out I put out
vlogs and that's like it's supposed to
be entertaining in some sense give
people behind the scenes of the
personalities that are working on
something but that's also just my
attempt to reach out and talk to someone
about something that's not news the the
other bit it's just it's just especially
now it's just so important to talk about
what's happening because everyone's so
confused and frustrated and so and
that's one of the reasons I left maker
early days it was it was business first
mm everything else second right my bank
account would look slightly different
but I'm so glad personally as far as the
work and what I'm doing
that I decided that I want to do it my
way that every move that I've done while
money might have been a part of it that
it's always been about what is the end
result of the content we could make or
we want to make sometimes some of that
some of those things did not fully get
fleshed out but it's why I'm still doing
it ten years out and I don't have to
it's because I really love this and I
really care about it yeah and you've had
some business ups and downs and ups and
bruises along the way and you just kind
of kept doing it and now you're fully
independent which yes just from
everything you just said I mean it's
like it's sort of like the greatest
thing that you can have as a creator
right it's so it's the best thing in the
world to be independent but you also
lose one thing right and that's the
ability to blame someone else right I
don't like to blame anyone that's
underneath me because their mistake is
my mistake right you put people in
control and that's ultimately like
that's you the net result is you so I
don't get to do that anymore but the
upside this is the 99% that's great yeah
how
you find that having the business part
of this and being the the head of the
company and all that do you like that or
do you find that to be that it takes you
away from the stuff that you really care
about that creating that content right
at times I especially when I initially
launched and we were setting everything
up and you get into the kind of like
that okay this is I'm remembering what
it was like to be back in college and
and staying at Panera Bread for way too
long and I was like doing everything
myself
and being on every phone call and
there's a point where that's a rush and
then at about a year a month and a half
it's like okay so I'm ready for I'm
ready for this a new step and so like
that's even something we're still
growing right so right now one of our
newest hires is gonna be our new CEO CEO
of oh yeah CEO Oh someone that can just
make sure that everything's working as
intended grows the company for us while
I'm in hopefully the more creative
sessions yeah where do you want to go
with all this like what's the now that
you're independent and I see it just
it's just grown and grown and grown and
I think you've hit something that's very
sort of similar to what I've tried to
build around here which is just but
could really I think the secret is just
basic decency like when I watch your
videos you strike me as fundamentally
decent and I feel like that's just kind
of yes and you also and you have a
commitment to the truth than you
actually are driving here both sides and
all that stuff but I think underlying
that is just kind of like a decency you
know I think the the one of the biggest
things that I've always found and it's
something my dad taught me when I was a
kid is even when you're disagreeing with
someone try try your best even no matter
how you how much you disagree with them
and and and and everything that they're
saying give them leave them with a door
open right to save some face to maybe
realize that part of what they were
thinking there is a misstep there
because when you put someone in a corner
although you're only really confirming
or all you're really doing is locking
them down in their belief right i I've
been there right when in in the past if
I've been talking to someone and they
hit me with something that proves like
something I previously thought was wrong
it almost feels like I'm being like
attacked
I'm being told I'm stupid and it's not a
great feeling so when you're arguing
with someone right if the real intent is
is to to hopefully promote truth right
hopefully promote the right thought
hopefully then you're leaving the door
open for them so you're saying that not
screaming at everybody that they're a
racist and a bigot and all that that
might not work but we're all guilty of
it I see you or sometimes I say
something about like the left right
absolutely and it's easy to talk in
generalities right sometimes you have to
talk in generalities on certain subjects
but sometimes we get a little swept away
with it and we end up causing the same
problems that we say that were fighting
against yeah I I find it and what sucks
is we're doing it openly on the Internet
in this in this grand experiment so
every time you falter everyone sees it
right and more importantly you see it
and it's just there and so hopefully you
don't do that thing that I just said
where where we then just lock down and
we're like well no there's a I'm
different for some reason that we grow
from it it's hard it's painful but I
think you just have to keep trying
you're gonna fail a lot but keep trying
yeah and we all make these mistakes and
it's interesting I don't remember what
the specific instance was but you did a
video on thinking it's time to do with
the terror attack or something and I
jumped the gun on neither the name of
the guy right I don't remember the
specifics if you do feel free to say it
but but I liked the fact that you you
said I like Dave Rubin he thought you
know screwed this one up or whatever you
said and I actually liked it cuz I was
like yay I did do it you didn't accuse
me of doing something that I do I
screwed up something I did correct it
once I found out but but often when you
correct things that gets much less
traction than the than the original
thing that's a whole other problem of
social media and all that but I thought
your intention wasn't to mock me you
were showing that even people that you
like right screw up sometimes and I feel
like everyone always wants to pretend
that they're so infallible and it's just
silly and it's important I think it's
important that people know that we are
all infallible but also that if we're
going to point out all the flaws of
mainstream media that we don't then just
repeat the same mistakes that were
criticizing right they're not perfect I
think the reason a lot of people get
angry is
there are people in the industry that
see themselves as higher right you see
it every time there's there's someone
that writes about a youtuber and a very
disrespectful light like we're all just
nothing yeah right we're this like this
fad even though this is the like the
swing of the new normal
right even if if CNN had the numbers
that you had they'd be thrilled I mean
if you shut CNN off at airport whatever
their numbers would be Phil DeFranco is
doing well I'd be interested damn close
let's put it that I think I mean I think
most a lot of the the up and comer is
definitely beat the the mainstream
outlets as far as the 18 to 35 as far as
full numbers I don't know your talk
about an international company I like to
puff my chest up a little something
there I know I know but I always have to
like bring myself down well at least in
terms of the influence that I see from
from what I can garner online and what
the conversations are about in people
that are talking about the right things
if I was to watch 10 minutes of one of
your videos on what happened in the
world versus watching 10 minutes of CNN
say doing another poll about Trump it's
like I actually learn a lot more so you
have a certain amount of by doing good
work you've now put yourself in a
position where there's a lot of pressure
on you to keep keep doing good work yeah
and the time I feel the most pressure is
any time I meet people I go to an event
or for some reason I'm in a public
setting for once in a long time and
people are like you're the only person I
watch which one I will always say please
watch more right please taking more
sources but then like that makes me feel
so horrible about off days where I'm
like you know what I got two hours to
sleep again I was like we're gonna try
and do like an eight-minute show and
it's it's a day that I personally feel
like I let people down even no matter
what the numbers are online I personally
feel it well I'll tell you about the the
state of things that people say that
kind of thing to you well I think it's
like we were saying earlier that people
don't know where to go or they just want
they do want a voice to bounce off of
but they want a voice that they can only
also respect that they don't see
themselves as always right but I also
think that by only posting like only
posting 10 to 18 minutes a day as a main
show I have an advantage over the
mainstream outlets who do have to do 24
hours right
so it's the reason why you have CNN
talking it's talking about that like a
plane crash for weeks and weeks and
weeks to the point where you have
someone talking about
the theory that the plane went into a
black hole right I don't have to we're
not that desperate
that we're taking crazy as yeah that
maybe would be in the 19th minute you
know yeah that's that's what happens
when it extends yeah what do you make of
just a general situation on YouTube
right now there there's a lot of people
very frustrated with YouTube from
creators to people watching people are
feeling
you know this whole D monetization thing
which you've done a bunch of videos on
there's a feeling that there's some
censorship being involved happening
right now I don't know if you noticed
this one I mentioned it on my live
stream earlier that we now have videos
you know for this month that I was gone
we had videos in our back end that were
not tagged not titled they had no
metadata attached to them and they were
demonetized
yeah that's something that we noticed
specifically on our vlog channel like
really not on the philip defranco show
which was a very strange we had a video
where we were just standing around
talking Auto flagged we change we change
the information multiple times I mean
this is like it's not a unique story
it's it's so weird and confusing and I
don't get it do you have any contact
with the YouTube people I had so much I
mean it took me literally two years to
finally I did the one work thing I did
last night I got one phone call with
them and I got no answers I put this on
youtube I want this to work you know
what I mean like yeah I'm not sitting
here so we can just talk [ __ ] about them
like I want it to be a better product
right because this is how we get our
stuff yeah we criticize the things we
love because I wanted to be better I
totally got that no I've had so I've had
the same contact at YouTube for about
seven years when you said that they were
gonna potentially offer someone from
their PR department to talk I was like
who is that yeah well they gotta be a
name yeah okay because I have a person
and I talked to them I get information
from them a lot of it ends up being
stuff that they haven't cleared to be on
the record so if you get a source that's
willing to talk publicly yeah that'd be
great
because otherwise all we get are people
having to talk to their partners and
then
YouTube uploading some video they don't
realize is condescending and everyone
gets angry yeah well you know we had
this back-and-forth going on with them
because people kept telling us they were
being unsubscribed from our channel and
we saw the growth just didn't make sense
and we got an email from someone there
saying yes there is a bug on your
channel or looking into it and then like
the next day they put up that video
remember that like six months ago those
two like oh I love it like no it's never
happened before we have no evidence
that's a great question you know it's
it's so frustrating
it's so frustrating sometimes it's it's
easy for it to feel so personal but I
think that there's so many moving pieces
there are times where people don't
realize things I've talked about certain
things on the show and then talk to
people at YouTube and they're like we
didn't know that was a thing on the site
that there was a problem yeah and so I
try I try whenever I can to also message
them before I cover a story not to give
them a heads up but just to go like if
there is something like an explanation
I'd love I'd love to be able to include
it but it is so frustrating especially
because for most people it's most of
their income right because they haven't
diversified or they haven't I saw your
new shirts focusing on March or having
some sort of alternate thing and I mean
the good end is if you have a good
product then you can use that as a way
to then convert audience that really
care about the content but otherwise
like you just right now you're just
[ __ ] yeah well that's why I think and
that's why I asked you the question
about the business side and how much you
put into that versus the creation
because I think for me it's actually by
doing this and as you know you're in my
hole this was my garage and now a studio
like the things that I talk about I'm
sure I've been able to put into practice
the beliefs that I have I've been able
to put into practice into the business
so it's more like the more that these if
YouTube closes a door on me on this or
whatever it's like yeah in life you just
got to be smart and go where the next
thing is right or else do you care how
people watch or where people wanna it's
a well especially thanks to like the
patreon and the Franco elite I don't
care right if they if they watch we're
gonna start may be uploading smaller
videos to Twitter as well just to get
the most traction everywhere
but if you're watching on Facebook
awesome if you're watching on YouTube
great if we then jump to another
platform fantastic I always treat my
videos like a shiny thing or like he's
right and just I want to leave those
things everywhere so no matter where you
turn it's right there I don't know about
your numbers because it's longer form
yeah but most of my views are now mobile
mobile or iPad or every now and then
it's like there's like a there's been a
jump for like X boxes and Smart TVs but
the like the numbers for computer are at
an all-time low
yeah do you think an offer could be made
to you that would swipe you up no hey Q
do it no no we were we were having a
conversation recently I was trying to
explain why I couldn't do certain things
and why I would never sell again and
when people hear that they hear
something that's emotional right they
hear something that's like never again
it was it's not like I'm suffering from
from some sort of thing it's just I
don't like the feeling of not being in
control Ryan so you could say okay well
that means just hold on to 51% but I
have a different mindset about it
because with this launch so much of it
was fan funded right and I'd feel like
I'm giving that to someone else rather
than putting it into the content there
are justifications where you could say
well by getting this person it affects
the content maybe maybe I'll evolve on
that I don't think so yeah but no never
never again do you ever have a moment
where you think oh I could save this
thing or cover this topic that could
actually now have my patrons might be
pissed at me or no or leave or anything
like that no I think that's one of the
benefits of trying to cover everything
as honestly and try and try and convey
other people's points of view is that I
mean every video I'm offending someone
yeah right and that's like it's strange
to hear for some people because there
are people that are like phil has never
had like a pinion that people disagreed
with which is an insane thing to say
right that's like going well everyone
thinks this one thing I've made people
angry and that's fine my hope is that
I've formed a relationship with people
where it's it's okay to do that that I'm
your friend or that person that you
you're friendly with that you talk about
stuff with that you don't necessarily
agree with that's that's my goal and
what's kind of great about that is yes
I'll always be shedding like some
subscribers I'll always be shedding some
some patrons but if I'm doing an
effective job I'll continue to grow over
time and so and so that's if anything
it's made me feel more comfortable that
there are that number of people that
that were that were supportive enough to
go like I might disagree with you but
let's do this yeah isn't that so also
the beauty of fan funding in general
whether you're doing it on patreon or
anything else it's like if I wanted to
sell out to my audience or whatever that
is I would I truly I would not even know
which way that meant well oh well I say
when you say sell out what's your
mindset because a lot of people have a
different mindset around it does that
mean no no sponsors does that mean no
yeah I mean look we have sponsors on our
audio podcast which by the way we didn't
do for three years on rest and we
finally did to make up some of the
YouTube's done we only accept ones that
I think are actually you know worth
worth except right but at this point I
feel very much what you said there I own
and control and operate my own business
the way that I want to it's successful
it's growing all of those things I don't
know what package could ever be put
together yeah I could make more money
but I'm not in it for that like I'm
doing all right so it's like I don't
know that something could supersede that
beautiful thing that we have you know
yeah it's like what every artist is
fighting for all the time in the history
of the world and and we have it for you
know hopefully more than a brief moment
it's beautiful yes I have nothing
everything you said is a guy packing all
right all that beauty aside of what of
what you've accomplished here
okay let's talk politics for a little
bit yay do you have a label that you put
on your snow I think I labeled myself a
libertarian years ago and I think a lot
of people use that I uh I forget what
moment it was there was uh someone asked
me actually someone bombarded me with a
question about wealth distribution
redistribution and I was just really
caught off guard and I didn't know
because I wasn't really at that time and
I would even argue now
well well versed in that right that
taxation is wealth and and that like
that big big push so I don't know I just
I just consider myself pretty liberal on
things like gay marriage trans rights
and bathrooms stuff like that and pretty
pretty pretty conservative when it comes
to business taxes things like that yeah
that's it so almost every seemingly sane
person that I meet these days says
something along those lines I'm socially
liberal and I'm fiscally conservative
now of course there's people on both
sides of that that does I think I think
what I've seen myself labeled like so a
lot of people say I'm a lot of different
things I think the closest thing I've
seen is I mean moderate a moderate free
speech liberal that's the closest thing
I could be like okay I mean that's fine
I mean it doesn't matter because the
moment you have a liberal in there
there's a good amount of people that are
gonna automatically dismiss you same as
there'd be a good amount of people if
you said you were a Republican yeah so
that's why I just go like I don't know
yeah
are you saying I haven't done the
perfect job in cleaning up the word
liberal didn't convince everyone that
achill liberal it did newscenter I
didn't get there with every single
person is out you're telling me never
have work to do no one no one ever
knowing it will find it and I mean those
the words are gonna change the labels
are gonna change I don't know I just I
don't want to stomp down on people's
rights and I don't want the government
in every facet of my life right that's
it yeah right there's a lot of holes you
can poke into a very broad statement
like that but when it comes to
generalities I think that's where I lie
specific issues I might have like a
weird outline or situation but otherwise
yeah yeah so I know you voted for Gary
Johnson in 2012 did you publicly say who
you I did not voted for this year you
didn't publicly say no I didn't vote for
either the main two but you're also not
saying you voted for Gary no I'm not
saying yeah alright so I mean I was
appointed by Gary Johnson as far as like
the way he was perceived by the public
and his responses to it I think I think
that if there was ever a chance and I I
hate saying it because I've met I've met
him
we had him on for the 2012 election he's
one of the nicest guys in the world's
great Matt agree was so cool but I was I
was really disappointed because it ended
up being this opportunity for a third
party to stand up in some meaningful way
and it felt you can blame the media all
you want the moments happened right you
didn't have to take certain things out
of context it just looked bad it looks
like a sideshow which is really
unfortunate because I think there are a
lot of like people a lot of really smart
people a lot of passionate people that
that believe in that of being a
libertarian the numbers weren't great
the whole perception wasn't great will
there be a chance in the future yes but
it's not gonna be in 2020 everyone's so
hopefully everyone's gonna be voting
hard and in 2018 but also 2020 yeah in
the month that I've taken off it seems
to me that that although I didn't think
the chasm could have gotten bigger it
seems like it actually got bigger just
even in the month
well what's fun for me is just seeing
though it's almost like it feels like
the WWE in a sense right there are
people rooting for people they didn't
think before like I saw some of my like
super left friends like for a moment
being pro banning on some things and and
the same thing with with the Attorney
General people just like flip-flopping
going issue to issue throwing out there
they're there some some misconception
some of their where they were
predisposed on people for this specific
issue and so that's been really really
interesting I think there there's still
a lot of people that are hardline but as
far as the people that are a little more
Center seeing seeing some of the way
that flows has been so interesting yeah
how big do you think the fringes
actually are because it seems to me
we're constantly being the conversation
is being just driven by the franchise I
mean so just just in my last day
background so now it seems like this
white nationalist thing is now sort of
regained some traction or whatever it is
and I find it hard to figure out well
how do these people have real attraction
is this a real group of people or is it
5,000 people with no influence or is is
making headway into our political system
or any of that you know I think it's I
think it's hard to tell because right
our our perception is reality and I
think a lot of people their perception
is that it is like two groups of like
not equal size but everyone's up some
sort of extreme right so everyone's
either anti-fog who are attacking people
right or everyone's a white supremacist
that's running people over with their
car right and there's a lot of people
that that are in the middle there now I
think when it comes to Charlottesville
and like I know a section of your
audience they're not going to be happy
with it but if if if I was if I was
there for the for the lulz if I was
there for the memes or I was there
legitimately for the statue
I would potentially have some issue and
personally want some separation to the
people throwing out like Nazi salutes
right to the to the people chanting old
Nazi slogans like that's there's a point
where I'm like I'm gonna peace out right
and I think that there were people like
that right 100% but you can't deny
seeing that number of people there for
for some completely shitty reasons yeah
right that's I think that freaked out a
lot of people you can say the numbers
being you know kind of blown out of
proportion
you can I think validly argue that we're
seeing a rise in part to people filling
a role that the media has said existed
and so they're just filling it up but
there's I mean there's a real there's a
real issue with that yeah well that's
the part that I think is hard to
decipher how much is real versus how
much is these guys that that led this
thing and again I'm just back on the
grid so I haven't even read enough about
this specifically but like how much is
just them doing exactly what will get
the media to cover them exactly what
will get their videos to go viral
exactly what will get the more Twitter
followers and all that nonsense and as
someone that was just off the grid
seeing us led by all the online stuff
now right particularly dangerous to me
right oh yeah well I mean I think
because extreme reactions to extremism
just it just it's cyclical 100% I mean
you start seeing
the KKK you start seeing them right next
to two white nationalists and then you
have that that poor woman that was hit
by that car right murdered and then all
of a sudden for some people that's gonna
make them go well an tyfa what they did
here it's not that bad it's just a
reaction right and we started off into
this justification but then we get stuck
in these these constant comparisons of
why if you can't prove that someone is
in the wrong then you're just gonna
prove that the other person is also
wrong right and that gets us nowhere and
it's and it's extremely frustrating and
I understand it because it's an
emotional response it's it's it's kind
of once we were like we were talking
about it's like a punch to the brain but
I don't I mean if you said how do you
how do you make it better I have no idea
I have zero clue on how you make it
better well I think you make it better
by pretty much doing what you're doing
which is giving room for a lot of this
stuff so hopefully hopefully okay
try and try to do that is there ever a
video or a story that you covered that
you think you completely screwed up like
looking back it's probably that you
really I live within like kind of a
36-hour window like before we were even
filming and I was trying to talk about
some of my past and I was just like I
have to like look off and try and
remember I mean I think part of that is
me trying to suppress stuff yeah but I
have really I live within a 36 hour
window so if I rightly get called out
for something i 100% want to look into
it because my goal is not to always be
right my goal is to to try and tell the
truth and to also grow personally yeah
and it seems to be working so far from
what maybe when I'm like a little older
I'll be locked down and all my beliefs
and that's just who I'll be until I die
that would be an interesting shift in
the business and in the content
yeah the new slogans gonna be [ __ ]
everyone I'm right what do you make of
this Trump gay
[Laughter]
we haven't said his name this whole time
no well no he's not Voldemort why he's
not it's not like that when people think
I mean there are people who literally
don't want to mention his name they're
giving him the Voldemort effect well I
think yeah I think when you make the big
claims Trump's a racist right you
automatically invalidate your
like 50% of the people you're talking to
can you do things that is going to
negatively affect a lot of people that
aren't his skin color yes I think that
certain times I think that he wants his
way so much that sometimes he's not
going to care that maybe the
Constitution gets in his way
but I think we also see that with other
world leaders is it this level of
extremism or more importantly is it more
in our faces every day right when I wake
up every morning at 6 o'clock I know
that Trump's probably tweeted an hour
ago about something today it was that he
was going to I think was on allow for
larger purchases with for South Korea
and and Japan as far as military
equipment and so I feel like it's just
more in everyone's face
right we wouldn't see the past president
saying like Dhaka exclamation mark so I
think I'm not saying that it's it's
right or wrong right a lot of people
that support Trump see that as the best
tool in the world they don't have to
wait for an official Fancy's stupid
press conference they're just they're
being told for the from the person they
voted for immediately right text
straight to my phone so I think it's
just more in in everybody his face and
so I think I mean he's a polarizing guy
like we I mean a lot of people don't
want it like don't talk about in the
same way but to a lesser extent Obama
was a very polarizing guy to a certain
section of people I think you don't
realize that a lot of people are just on
the other end of that this time yeah
what do you make of just sort of the way
everyone deals with it so yeah you know
you wake up any given morning you know
he's gonna tweet something crazy I I
don't think that ever I've really gone
after one of the tweets specifically
because it just seems like such theater
and sideshow to me like they're all liar
like I'm a firm believer that pretty
much all politicians especially at that
high level they're lying either biomed
like there's just a system of
half-truths and omissions constantly
right and yes Obama lied the way that we
liked presidents to lie or or said that
you know like red line which was a lie
that I think the red line in Syria that
even though I didn't want to go to war
in Syria you laid out the red line
right or you'll be able to dock tur no
matter what you can keep right that so
that's a more specific example right you
can keep your doctor right they knew it
was a lie and they still did it but he
did it in the in the sort of you know
wearing a suit speaking nicely giving
long speeches the notion of this that
like they lied in a certain way trumps
just lying in a different way it's gross
and disgusting and I care about ideas
and thoughts and all that stuff so I
don't want the conversation to be about
this but I just see it as a different
version of also different version of
lying so I see that but I also go like
there's also something a little bit
defending it by the no I just see it's
not like I attack you for that no
because I think you're making me think
that yeah the main difference then is
that you have someone that's lying in a
different way but at the same time half
of their shtick is saying that other
people are longer right and so like that
that's like a different layer like I've
talked about in the past but several
times like literally in tweets where
he's saying this is fake news it what
he's saying is they lie and I think
that's I think that is a prime example
of some of the stuff that's like really
messed up and wrong I'm not someone that
wakes up going like [ __ ] Trump right how
am I gonna skewer the guy today and I
end up finding myself having to defend
them when they get attacked for stupid
things like when people went after
Melania Trump cuz she wore high heels
right and they're like they're gonna go
to they're gonna go to Texas cuz a
hurricane Harvey and what you're gonna
do in heels what's what's the what's
FLOTUS gonna do right whether it's
whether it's Melania or any other any
other person effort like it it's just
frustrating it's there's there is a
reason to be bothered by a lot of the
stuff that's happening and I think the
place I find myself the most frustrated
is the things that are illogical or
don't matter right yeah so and we're
slammed with those those are the ones
were slammed well and so and that's
right that's kind of like the the
problem is when when you stress out
about these minor things and you give
them especially because of a 24-hour
news cycle or the fact that so many of
these these organizations are so
competitive and they're giving things
that don't matter airtime compared to
when they really mess up and it is a
really big deal you just take away how
important the other thing is right and
and
you won't and you end up just kind of
hurting your own argument when you have
the stronger argument because you're
complaining about everything yeah how
much do you think social media is just
adding to the craziness I don't even
mean Trump's Twitter but I mean just the
general like just as I'm getting back on
like just looking at that and seeing how
the same people fighting about the same
things and it's like does any of this
matter does any of this well then you're
gonna just end up in some like
existential yeah right I mean my whole
view on life is that none of this kind
of matters while I exist and what I try
and provide for like my family and
everyone I interact with I hope that I
put more good in the world than I then I
take but as far as as far as does any of
it matter the bickering I don't know
part of its part of its WWE [ __ ]
fake like not fake fighting but like
meaningless fighting and then there's
the stuff where lives are gonna be
affected right so when we talking about
Dhaka today right that's that's like a
real thing now everyone complaining
about it online
no that's just noise right but then at
the end of the day you're you're talking
about real lives a real impact right so
some of it matters but a lot of it does
not it it's the it's the beauty and the
downfall of giving everyone a massive
megaphone yeah and I'd rather have it
this way I'd rather have everyone have
the chance to get their voice out but of
course that does that does come with
some stuff
who art likes just some people in
general or organizations that you trust
cuz I get that one all the contras
anyone man no I don't I uh well when
you're when you're doing research and
you got your guys looking at stories and
everything everywhere you look
everywhere even when we provide links to
sources we don't even include everything
we try to get as many as many different
viewpoints and ways that something's
covered as possible because sometimes
they're places that miss things maybe
they omitted it maybe people just think
they omitted it and then there's a
completely different viewpoint of a
completely different angle and my goal
is to kind of as much as I can cover a
little bit of both sides in the sense of
at least understanding where the angles
coming from even if I massively disagree
with it but I mean as far as like if we
talk about individuals I don't know if I
would
automatically say trust where I respect
or I'm interested in obviously like I'm
doing this so you to an extent to a fact
everyone knows that you're crazy
communist no I uh we were talking
earlier ben shapiro always fascinated by
what he's gonna say or was kind of like
a viewpoint and then a few others that I
don't want on a call by name but yeah
isn't that funny you don't want to call
my name even though you'd be probably
saying something nice about them but I
get it cuz then it puts this odd
pressure right but then it's like oh
you've endorsed them and now they screw
up tomorrow and say well especially
because you don't know everything about
every single person right they can be
like well in 1999 ever like well
apparently I'm a Nazi now yeah what do
you do to get out of the the mess and
the matrix so so as I have a week and a
half ago I've recently started writing
my well real bike and then also a
cycling bike it's the only way that I
can get energy anymore since I am way
too overweight and I've stopped taking
adderall a long time ago so it's like
it's like this beautiful burst energy so
like right after we're done here I'm
gonna go home knock out 45 minutes
slowly slowly gonna make my life a
little better both mentally and
hopefully physically does adderall lead
to jump cuts which came first a dural
era jump cut the jump cut
yeah the jump cut the lateral I think I
think it was right before I did my first
tour I initially got just because I was
having a hard time multitasking but I
think part of that was probably just I
was putting too much on myself but it's
so incredibly easy to like it's it's
incredibly habit-forming and the first
month that I stopped taking it it was it
was like moving through water yeah it
was rough do you have a DD or something
over you I was I was prescribed the
medication and so they said I did yeah
but I think if you ever go to a doctor
it's one of the most over prescribed
medications easily although I will say
in California they're a little weird
about it like you can only go month to
month whereas in yeah right yeah whereas
in
Atlanta you could get like several
months I don't know if the law has
changed but that was that was the
biggest difference and I was like you
guys are letting people smoke weed and
you're freaking out about this man which
was so the reason I say it like that is
it was so alien to me because I had
lived in a place where it was obviously
illegal right you are okay with weed
yeah yeah I don't smoke it anymore just
because I feel like especially now I'm
like always having to be in dad mode I'm
like it's so weird I'm so stressed about
something going wrong yeah so I should
probably smoke that but I'm worried that
if I smoke I'm not gonna be like there
to be able to handle the situation yeah
and so that's why I've like stopped
speak of the dad mode as you might have
a second kid while we're right now so
your wife puts up DeFranco family videos
and i assume the new baby will be
involved and that's well there's at
least probably will probably be there
yeah how do you where do you try to draw
that line of like how much of what you
guys do is public versus private does
she come to you and talk about any of
this stuff yeah well I mean we the thing
is like we don't we don't share a bunch
it's usually I feel like she puts a lot
of work into the editing and I'm like
really proud and impressed because I
don't do any of that for myself anymore
yeah but no I mean I think it's gonna be
a bigger part of the conversation as our
oldest gets older because I mean we've
YouTube's been around long enough there
have been family vloggers that of now
like the kids grow have grown up and
they're like a big part of the vlog and
it is definitely different I know and I
don't wanna mention them by name but
like there are youtube families that
have had to remove their kids from
school right because people were showing
up to the school trying to either see
them or take them and you also have to
take into account if the kid actually
wants to do it right and making it and
if it's what mom and dad are doing not
making it so they don't feel guilty if
they don't want to because I've seen
examples of that as well and that's not
even taken to account that you're part
of a family vlog and then you're going
into school with people that are
watching your family vlog and so it can
make you like a celebrity but if
something horrible happens when
something happens with your parents
everyone's gonna know about it so I
don't know I think I like sharing it
because or I like seeing it because I
loved that all of a sudden I saw a
little gif of my son when he was six
months old and I was like I think I know
what video that's from and I got to
watch this video of my kid now I could
do that personally it seems like such a
weird alien thought of why would I edit
a video that I don't put out to the
public or share because and I'm not
trying to be cliche or corny in that way
but when you get used to sharing it with
people it almost ends up being like an
extension of family extended family but
family where it's but it does have this
potential to become everyone criticizing
your life it's why I never fully jumped
into I'm going to be a full-on vlogger
because people talking about me is
completely different than people talking
about they them thinking that my opinion
is garbage right completely different
extremes yeah all right wait you gave me
a couple of things sorry I know I wanted
I ramble through all my thoughts no no
that was good but you said something
sort of you kind of had a throwaway
there that I thought was a great moment
that you don't do any of your editing
anymore no must have been a beautiful
beautiful moment I mean I know for me
that when I've been able to take certain
things off my plate and give it to my
team or just add different things or
focus more on writing the direct message
river-like then I get to do what I'm
supposed to be doing that must have been
a beautiful moment it was so scary
ya know it was so scary because the way
that I used to edit the show so you were
talking about jump cuts I would
literally say a sentence see if it
worked
say a sentence see if it worked as I
edited in iMovie and I think I term I
think I yeah I recorded directly with I
think the iMovie camera at first or
something I had connected that could
read that camera and yeah I would just
sup guys welcome to the show okay
completely horrible process like it's
why the tone is different in the old
videos but I felt like I had control at
the time I thought it was like I was am
i editing something special and the
moment I introduced people or brought
an editor it was the best thing in the
world because it does for you up to just
focus on that yeah all of a sudden the
videos can be longer you can focus more
on the creative make sure or now
fact-checking are you ever worried that
you're gonna hand them something and
they're editing your words that you know
they're gonna mangle something or behind
the fear plot well I mean I always
review oh my god yeah no I'm uh I try to
at least like even today I was like guys
we got to do this early I got to get out
get everything up but no I mean I'm sure
my editors have like a [ __ ] fill folder
for like if it's ever like you're fired
all of a sudden there'd be like a three
minute long montage of me saying like
lines that I ended up going and cut that
but no I mean it's it's you have to open
yourself up it'd be a little vulnerable
especially once you bring people into
the process because especially with what
we're talking about I feel like I don't
know about you but I'm a little fluid
with my thinking on some things and so
like as I'm covering it I'm trying to
digest the whole situation and so as I'm
filming my opinion might change on
something fresh actually if some new
information comes out so and that's also
you have to worry about that because
then you're doing something based off of
information that's not fully updated
right and then you know damn well sure
that someone's gonna find it five years
ago saying look he said that it was the
reverse yeah and it's like well yeah I
evolved how about that yeah well that's
what every now and then I'll get into
like an argument with someone and
they'll be like look at this video you
did seven years ago where you said this
kind of off-color thing and I was like
well one you took it out of context to
just kind of I was kind of a dick I
would say things I thought were like
super edgy and and that's how you make
jokes and it's just horrible
like not like I saw something in a video
that you did for many years ago saying
about being the type of feminist you are
or something and and you had some joke
about something but it was like some sex
joke about women are saying like it was
just a joke and I don't even remember
exactly what it was but it was like I
saw somebody attacking you over and it's
like it's always something I don't know
I don't know what the specific was so
I'd be able to like comments on that
specifically
because of my 36-hour memory but it I
have 36-hour memory these days is
actually white
for what's going on in the real world
all right let's shift a little bit
because so this episode so I've been
trying to get you on for every one we
had together schedules to match up and
everything but learn Liberty who's one
of our partners did partner up with us
to do this and when when they usually
send us professors or something you've
never worked in flarin Liberty er to any
contact with them ever but they said to
me if Phil wants to do a show we'd love
to sponsor the show and I said that to
you and you said immediately whatever
they were gonna they give like an
honorarium to our guest usually it's for
travel sometimes people come in from
other countries or whatever but you said
immediately I don't want the money I
want the money to go to the PKD
Foundation oh yeah the plan needs you
are so yeah so I want to talk about that
a little bit so tell me about PKD and
why you care about it well I care about
it for two reasons
my dad has it PKD is polycystic kidney
disease essentially to kind of simplify
it
your kidneys are eventually going to
fail and and so my dad had it he ended
up losing function and his kidneys got
to be on dialysis for a while I have it
so and my kids could have it because
it's it's passed down through great
carriers like myself but no I mean it's
it's it sucks I don't know I always I
never know how to talk about it because
it's such a depressing thing to me and
and I always try and put that stuff out
of my mind and think that I'm life's
never gonna catch up with me but no I
mean it's just people's kidneys are
gonna fail it affects a lot of people
pkt cure is is out there trying to help
fund research therapy Kady walks and I
also just didn't want to take your money
they wouldn't have been giving the money
to me by the way they give it to the
guests so but I want I want to be on
here for uh Anna I don't it sounds weird
but if I took money for being here
it feels dirty I want to be here yeah
the record we don't pay our guests ever
this is just when learn Liberty does
things you know why you live why you
live today
you know we have to we have to Yui and
Dave we have to have some drama so that
you actually alright so so we can boost
each other we should create drama all
right let me figure out ways we can
finish with a little drama I'm excited
for your diss track yeah here we go
let's try to create some drama do you
think the social justice things just
imploding all together I think it's what
we say about talking about generalities
yeah I think I think I think there's a
problem right moving to California
pushed me more Center being online and
seeing how like how crazy things were
getting as far as if things you would
label SJW right that pushed me more
Center talking in a video six years ago
and using the the wrong pronoun pronoun
accidentally on a story about a trans
person pushed me more Center and and
further not even Center just pushed me
away yeah and when you see things like
we covered the oh I'm gonna mess up her
name the the trans model who has just
got booted from a lore'l campaign
because she went on this rant where she
said like it's all white people white
people violence and then she said she
was taken out of context because she was
talking around the events of
Charlottesville and it's like no you can
let's say it's not even in a back or
it's in a vacuum or it's not you're
still no matter if someone's an ally
you're still using this this
all-encompassing language and you can
try and justify it but it ends up
pushing people away right people that
could be your allies and I'm not saying
tone yourself down for for people to
like you
right just understand that if you're
gonna use all-encompassing language that
it's it's gonna it's not great it's not
great for your cause but as far as is it
imploding I don't know I mean as far as
generalities I'd hope that people stop
being ridiculous but care about actual
people right I think that's the goal
right I think that it then becomes this
[ __ ] crazy toxic thing where you have
was it Evergreen State University where
you have places like that of students
going up to a teacher and and saying
that because he's talking with his hands
which oh my god I would be committing a
head
that that's a microaggression see this
is how you do it that's insane
it's insane we're just it doesn't need
to be that extreme yeah well I guess by
imploding that's what I meant that the
the hysteria and those types of things
are they're just pushing good people
Center which I think ultimately is
actually good so yeah there's always
going to be a certain amount of hysteria
right on both extremes of course but
that the more there is the more you make
decent people you know a guy who
accidentally screws up a pronoun who who
isn't a trans Fobo or anything like that
it makes them really and go maybe this
isn't exactly where I'm supposed yeah by
being extreme you make extremis like
that's it's it's something we said
earlier and it's just it's just true in
my opinion yeah oh these are all your
opinions just my opinion ah
leaving the door opens with that I
believe in the door open yeah I feel we
should finish on on free speech in
general because I'm gonna say it once
and you'reyou're a big free speech guy
right you basically I think you're a
free speech absolutist right is there I
think so yeah I'm trying to think I was
like I'm so intrigued by the thought and
I think I've heard your opinion on it of
because because people are going around
and they have the swastika zone because
it is a symbol for like this this
horrible group this horrible thing that
that somehow then changes the
conversation on free speech what are
your thoughts so I'm just hearing this
literally just as I just got back on I
read one article about this this morning
about this idea that these ideas are so
inherently linked to violence right
right that they in an in and of
themselves around that the the image or
the words that these people are saying I
don't agree right don't agree it sucks
as I've mentioned many times I had
family members on both sides my family
died in the Holocaust I grew up around
Holocaust survivors so this is not
something that I hold lightly any of
what these people were doing in
Charlottesville any of this these are
disgusting people that are doing this do
they have the right to say and do
horrible things actually the Supreme
Court has affirmed right that right with
you know the March in Illinois so it
sucks like it doesn't feel good you know
you mean like we all want to say
something to you that makes me feel good
about yeah [ __ ] these guys in
get out there and punch your Nazi you
know like like all these quitter
warriors want you to punch Nazis but you
know they never do it but they all want
you to punch them all at least to have
Touche Touche but it doesn't feel good
but I don't want to trade something that
doesn't feel good to sacrifice what I
believe is right most important thing
here which is free expression and I
think you had only a really good point
is it doesn't feel good and that's why
it's one of those things of when you say
a free speech absolutist I like yes but
this one thing has me feeling dirty now
look if but but there can be there are
legal reasons why you can sort of hedge
that a little bit which is if he's up
there screaming kill the Jews were
hanging black people now there now
there's a criminal part to this right a
call to violence right but short of that
I think you have to let these I think
you've said it somewhere I read a quote
in something about that if you just if
you stifle these people you always make
them stronger I mean that's sort of
right and I think that there's also
there's also this weird line that you
end up creating there's a youtuber I
forget his real name but he goes by the
name of count dank dank EULA count dank
EULA and he is yes yes I know the work
of counting yes yes
no but and he's he's having to go and I
don't know if it got postponed I know
it's supposed to be sometime around
right around now but he's facing jail
time because he put out a video of him
jokingly making his dog do the Nazi
salute freezing to death and where what
what can I believe well is it is it
Scotland okay but it's not the United
States so that's why I like you yeah
elsewhere
yeah and you're like oh [ __ ] you see
what happened right and so it's like and
so that's why you end up caring about
the line right of holding on something
because then it becomes that which I
will say it's distasteful in context
it's it was a really stupid joke because
his whole argument was his girlfriend
loves the dog so much that he wants to
ruin the dog and so the best way to ruin
something is to make it a Nazi right in
context it's like okay yeah but but then
outside of that there's there such a
negative feeling that when when do you
start doing things that are just
ridiculous
yeah like the fact that he's facing jail
time I think is ridiculous
I'm open to other people being sensitive
about it being offended by it but the
fact that a court can go that's illegal
that's crazy yeah and so I think that's
why I try to at all times understand
that that free speech should be that
open no matter how despicable we think
it is yeah not the dog the actual Nazis
just sucks like it just and that's what
that's the part of the conversation that
I think people are always afraid to have
like we're all everyone if you ask
anyone there are you for free speech yes
but then the second you get them to a
place that's uncomfortable for them then
they say well that's the one as the one
I can't write but it's like yeah it
really is sucky but you can't be up that
you can't be calling for violence you
can't obviously be committing violence
but short of that you got to let people
do otherwise you actually make them the
victim which is what they really want
more than anything else you know they
want to trade in that victimhood and
that's I don't want to trade in that
they'll DeFranco I feel I should leave
you to your to your wife yeah well I
don't know unless your producer is the
worst person in the world I don't think
she had the baby we said we were going
to give you a fair warning whatever they
felt this was so gripping so gripping
that you have another key that I've
missed my shot by the birth of my child
yeah I would have to make everything I
do from here on out to destroy your show
[Laughter]
from Oh a great promo for you but
actually that would be great you do what
you gotta do I'm so glad we finally did
this now I know I'm gonna bump into you
halfway down the street probably maybe
one day if I ever go outside yeah but
now you got this indoor bike too yeah so
I get to just stay inside air
conditioned since I lived and I've lived
in California for like seven years and
100 degrees is just unbearable to me
yeah it's it's made me so weak alright
well it was a pleasure which I expected
it to be and for more on Phil you can
find him making sense of the madness is
that too much pressure no I like it
might be made slogan he's making sense
of the madness on the philip defranco
show which is right here on the YouTube
you
[Music]